[Music]
welcome back to off the record we're
talking about whatever we want
whatever
whatever literally whatever it's sort of
ironic actually yeah because we can't
exactly talk about exactly what we want
because the cameras are on yeah
it's called there's a couple of things
we really want to talk about
but we can't but it's off the record so
it doesn't really it's never really on
video
you know what i mean yeah say whatever
it's whatever we want on camera on
camera
yeah i feel like off the record is just
the name of the show it used to be like
allegations against any of you guys nah
i think we're pretty clean i think we're
in good shape yeah real good shape yeah
how about you
the show called tiger belly dude okay
you know what did animal rights come
after you guys tell you did you license
that name they're just something crazy
you know kalala actually i don't know
i'll just say this story kaleila
basically it's off the record anyways no
one's going to see this
i think she might have i think she might
have actually told the story on here but
i think another incident happened where
she had her dog right or maybe her
friend's dog in her car and they were
like instagramming right now ig stories
yeah did she get canceled for jacking
off the dog that's a different time okay
she didn't get canceled for that that
was more of a cultural thing for the
filipino people okay uh those
international waters
one of their dogs got a hard dick in the
car and they were filming it right and
they go and they were pointing at it and
then everyone freaked out saying like
you're shaming the dog for having a hard
day no [ __ ] way what are we supposed
to do here again i agree
they're wrong they should be canceled
uh give me your position on that uh
see those eyes for the shifting
sexually it's sexually harassing and
there's no consent the dog had a boner
and they were like i don't want you to
see the body say you had a dick right i
have a dick okay good yeah you happen to
just say you have one
and then let's say you have a boner
right i have a hard one great let's say
you have a hard one yeah two women two
women want to suck it point your dick
right oh are you do you enjoy that
well i would say yes as a straight cis
asian american male 1 i would have to
say
oh hell yeah
but i can't speak for everyone out there
because you can't assume that everyone
is me
here's why i think that that was
actually [ __ ] up because the dogs if
you say bad dog dogs feel bad yeah am i
wrong
dogs feel emotions you can make you can
scold a dog and make a dog feel but you
also can't assume what language the dog
speaks because you have a german
shepherd only understands germans yeah
all i know is that when a dog is licking
his own [ __ ] he doesn't like it when
people are watching him that's true the
dog looks his own [ __ ] he's speaking
man
not all dogs
i don't have chinese people
[Laughter]
did somebody actually get in real
trouble for that i don't think anyone in
real trouble is just the amount of uh
internet uh people are really like
offended by that yeah i would have been
offended because i'm like why why isn't
anyone sucking it yeah that's [ __ ] up
someone should jack that dog off right
someone should eat his [ __ ] while
they're jet while the jack and him no
exactly there's something about how
serious your eyes are when you say
somebody should have sucked it off
somebody should have sucked it up yeah
somebody yeah somebody there is a level
of angst like on the internet where
people can't wait to jump off on some
[ __ ] yeah like a dog's boner
i don't know if it was like that before
was it like 2015 was it like people so
jumpy less people had access
oh maybe from 2015 to like now imagine
how many kids now have like ability and
access whether it be homeschooling to
like new cell phones or whatever
technology like and grandmas and grandpa
do you remember the culture of the
internet yeah they know how it used to
be in the 90s oh yeah remember the aol
days
neopets yeah remember that [ __ ] [ __ ]
avenue 56k i was rough
and as time progressed i saw a
difference in internet culture man yeah
i think also kids these day feel are
just young people just feel like they
have to save the world i think jordan
peterson actually talked about this how
he's like kids these days kids these
days i just feel like uh he said
basically people are not even worried
about their own self like care of their
lives how their own life is doing where
they feel they need they need to like
save the world where it's like how can
you save the world if you have no
leaders that have like
taken care of themselves yeah it's like
it's like a lot of the the activists out
there want to save the world but they
can't even save their own bedroom
because it looks like garbage i'm down
for that wash my car i don't care if
your car is clean come wash it for free
it's so weird like you know the
environment i don't think that's what
they're saying
what do they say okay remember maybe
they're saying
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you guys weren't like activisty
in high school like i remember listening
i'm trying to survive not getting beat
up in georgia
in 1994. well okay like i feel like
everyone's had a little bit of taste
with socialism in high school and
activism and i never i don't even know
what socialism was and i don't even
think i was though that's too big of a
word for me it was things like asb asb
god yeah i think i was just trying to
smoke cigarettes and get high and like
that was later on good old days do you
the cigarettes dude swisher cigarettes
swisher sweets swishers sweets black
miles well i had i had my awakening in
ninth grade i studied karl marx i
started learning about alternative
things that i'm like why is this system
the way it is why are there poor people
why are there rich people how come we
can't you know
live in a decent neighborhood can we
help everybody why can't everyone be
rich too there's a lot of abundances
right so in ninth grade i studied all
these things but i also had educators uh
that were
pretty
stupid extreme
there were there was they're a
full-blown communist you did that in
like high school in ninth grade and then
i said what was this gardena high oh and
then i had center of communism yeah yeah
big communist because you got to think
about it right in the inner city a lot
of the educators became that way because
they were part of the social uh rights
movement and they were fighting for a
lot of things and like and then and then
that got them
to get
asian american studies into the schools
or whatever right you're the only one
thinking like this was other classmates
that were thinking this philosophically
at such a young age or some adam smith
[ __ ] in there i think i was
pretty alone alone on it but then
i i went through this phase so i could
kind of feel the generation now that's
doing it that's pretty deep yeah but
then later on you realize that it is a
bottom-up view and not a not a whole
view it's a it's a piece of the story
not the whole story yeah so then when
you are uh of the uh the like the
workers group or if you're like a
socialist you're looking at the world
from a worker's point of view not the
person who's like
sees the whole thing like a leader's
role right or like like whatever pulling
the lens back
yeah so i think that in all experiments
of socialism they failed
and then so that's why i was like i
don't think that's a great idea guys
because there's a reason why people are
running away from socialists and
communist countries to america and then
i gave it up and i joined the gang so
there you go i thought that that was a
that was a better alternative or was it
like a hierarchy is it gang member
full-blown capitalism yeah is it gang
meritocracy or is there like diversity
situations in that like affirmative
affirmative actions were you in a social
game
no i want i was looking for an extremist
group to join but they weren't any and
people thought it was lame part of this
video
i was looking at the penny saver under
extremist
nothing electrician
al chida
i knew about al qaeda before it was a
popular thing to know about you knew
about al qaeda i was just worrying about
the ddr club i wasn't [ __ ] figuring
out like streaming well because you go
to this journey right now that is real
injustice you go through this journey of
injustice and then you feel like you got
to do something about it right
and that's why i go oh [ __ ] no wonder
terrorists they recruit young people
they recruit kids at 12 years old or 13
years old and then you brainwash them
and they become your uh soldiers right
because i think there was a time in my
life when i was like oh that's so cool
how the kamikaze guys died for their
country like the kamikaze pilots would
dive into these um
uh american warships right and i was
like dang they really gave their life
for the country and then they became um
spirits and and now they're remembered
as heroes and i'm like that's so cool i
thought that when i was 13 14 years old
how do you think they sound when they're
in the plane doing it they're probably
crying their eyes out and saying oh i
don't want to do it last minute you know
yeah but at 13
your idea of what a hero is and also
we're also brainwashed too like we're
we're thinking soldiers fighting wars
and stuff for heroes yeah they are but
at the same time they're a little
brainwashed too right like you have to
teach somebody to kill strangers for the
sake of you know your country you think
they're sold a dream
exactly so then now it's like how do you
what's the good thing and what's the bad
thing they all seem the same to me
everyone's fighting for their power and
freedom do you ever ask your parents
about like these questions like because
i asked my parents or like how come that
kid is rich how come they can go to like
the baseball game whenever they want how
come we can't and then my my mom would
be like oh they're they're family their
parents were born here so they just have
access to way more resources we're kind
of a little bit behind and i'm like okay
cool and then i'll go but what about
that asian family that so that's an
american family i get that that's an
asian family and then they're like well
that guy's like into real estate it's
just much more lucrative yeah that guy's
jason chen
yeah
i'm like oh how come dad doesn't get
into real estate and he's like oh cause
dad only has a junior high degree so he
can only get this level of job so i
think because of that it just stopped
there it never made me question the
system it just made me go oh higher
education work hard more resources i i
guess i see why we're poor uh did you
ever ask these questions
peekaboo today's video is brought to you
by neutral okay
so i started growing out my hair this is
about a year now
and apparently
this is a lot for a year
and i guess with genetics and whatever
it depends
on a lot of people some people it takes
them
years to get to how much hair i got and
i'm working with neutral fall on this
fun little project i just got this about
a month ago and it's a pretty cool
supplement it's formulated with potent
botanicals to help you grow real full
strong hair and i said well i already
got the hair
but let me just start taking these
because
what if i got super healthy hair and on
top of that if my hair grows fast
what else is gonna grow am i gonna get
like hair like super super like strong
and long and whatever and it like goes
all the way down to my ankles in a month
i don't know but i thought it'll be a
fun experience to do because it's 100
drug-free yeah there's like 80 million
men and women i think that experience
thinning hair so it's pretty common
what's cool about neutrophil is that in
clinical studies 72 of males
uh experienced more scalp coverage from
taking it and it's easy it's just in
pill form you take it has all these
things that also help increase like your
your nail health your hair health your
skin health so if that's something that
you really want to focus on i think
neutral is awesome so you can grow
thicker and healthier hair just go to
nutrafull.com and use our promo code otr
to get 15
off of your first month's order and
that's the best deal you're going to
find anywhere and this is only limited
to our u.s customers that's nutrafull
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com use the promo code
otr to get 15 bucks off your first
month's order and get strong beautiful
healthy hair i can't wait to see what's
gonna happen you're gonna grow it all
the way down to your ass
if
neutral fall helps me do it by a month
we'll see
this is growing actually
i did early on in elementary school and
i realized that they didn't have the
answers because those answers sound
sensible it's like oh yeah you know you
gotta do they sound sensible in this day
and age to me it still does it does it's
like hey
you know
they earned enough they saved up they
bought homes they did this and that
that makes sense right yeah but this is
how i was told i was like i don't want
to go to school today why because i
don't get it like
why do i have to go and they're like you
need a job and then i'm like why do i
need a job this is me in elementary
school right as a kid and then they're
like well it's common sense everyone
needs to work and then i'm like
but why there's people in this world
that live in villages and tribes and
they don't have to work work like
you know they can hunt or whatever and
then they're like
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard
they're like [ __ ]
yeah so i'm like but you still haven't i
literally got my ass beat for being a
smart ass right so i'm but i have a
thirst for this answer yeah and i'm like
well if you guys don't know they
couldn't answer why we should go to
church they couldn't answer all these
things and then uh like you know
recently like i would say like 10 years
recently my mom would be like yeah we
just i feel bad because you made me
question my reality and it was scary so
i beat your ass to shut you up
i remember asking my parents about like
you know why what's the difference
between jesus and santa which i think
everyone has that thought yeah yeah and
it's just like they're like shut up shut
the [ __ ] up
when you guys were kids were you did you
ever think you were ever sold on santa
like being a real hell yeah of course
like i had a bad child you're talking to
some not very smart people with my
friends i think probably up to when i
was at least five or six i think i
wanted to believe it was real because i
could get two presents have you not seen
santa like at the supermarket do you
guys remember um do you guys remember
when you
you guys remember when you found out it
wasn't real i remember mine was my mom
said at a store she said pick two toys i
picked two toys and then like christmas
those exact same toys were
in the [ __ ] box but she had me put
this she wrote she told me
magic
she requested it you don't know that's
how it works they just know right i
forgot you're good at branding i'm just
when did you guys when did you win way
better than jeff walker did you tell
your parents when you found out
uh yeah i asked my mom and she just
smiled and said
you don't believe
you don't believe i felt bad she just
said you don't believe i walked away i
didn't know what did you stop getting
presents from santa i did
you [ __ ] it up for yourself i did i
was like those are the same two toys
that you i saw you i picked out you put
in the store and put on a different
shelf and said hey let's go check out
and then i gotta go back and then like
put it all together
eventually my parents just got so lazy
it was all the same wrapping paper from
santa and from them like whatever guys
yeah santa said steve's dad exactly how
how old were you i think i was like
fifth grade did you guys have a fifth
grade you [ __ ] idiot not scared
i was like three two i was i was late
for me too i thought it was like first
grade or something holy [ __ ] yeah by
fifth grade you should know are you
gonna raise taika
with sansa in his life yes for sure yeah
you have to yeah do you guys have a city
north pole
or no oh what so in cerritos like during
christmas time
you can write to santa and i remember
writing like you know you write the
sound this is what i want and all that
stuff and then we would go to the
mailbox and mail it and then it would be
like santa claus
uh like north pole p.o box cerritos and
i'm like wait saddle lives
my mom's like sometimes he comes here
and i'm like all right and then she
would actually get her better back so it
really ingrained in me
santa's at the tustin auto center
you guys could go to santa's village in
lake arrowhead and he's there year-round
you can go to santa's village at the
[ __ ] every mall
every major mall in every major city
like have you taken tekka to santa yet
or no um he's been too dumb to recognize
him i think this will be the first year
he knows okay say he's and i was gonna
use that i was an ass kid another word
but that word we will not use
say you show up to the mall and and that
santa that day not that fat
uh
beer i turn around and then say and he's
vietnamese are you gonna be like are you
still gonna be taika i'd be like hey
look at santa you're gonna be like i
have an image of how i think santa is i
want my son to know yes you guys believe
in white santa you only only believe in
what i only believe in white santa
because our favorite
christmas movie well two of them is home
alone and elf so it's gotta look like
the one in elf oh
great santa can only be white santa i
agree
honestly honestly i agree yeah if he
doesn't like santa sounds fun though
blackstone is great yeah he's he's got
like a merlin he's gotta look like
[Laughter]
yeah i got in trouble for whistle
blowing that there's no santa at school
bro you are a little did you call it
whistleblowers
he's a [ __ ] whistleblower he's been
hacking the school like website
santa's not real
i was like in kindergarten or first
grade and i found out right so that's
why i was like
when they were doing this i was like i
can't stand for this [ __ ] i had been
social justice back in the back in the
days you know what i mean
you're the original sjw i'm like teacher
did you know i even thought the adults
were stupid because i was like did you
know that santa's not real did you know
it's just a make belief it's a big
belief does he speak english
and then they pull me to the side and
then they're just like don't do this
like
i was like [ __ ] dude and the kids were
crying by the
dude you know the truth you must stop it
sounds like a south park episode yeah
man [ __ ] neo jesus i thought i was
doing the right thing cause i was like
they gotta know hey you weren't this is
[ __ ] i tried to wake them up man but
they wouldn't they weren't
that's what he actually said in his
speech to the kindergarten class all of
these won't kill oh the pulpit yeah the
steak tastes better when you're in dude
did that movie so good it still holds up
i'll say that still good every time you
watch it you learn something new like
what i don't know
[ __ ] liar i hate when people say that
[ __ ] and they they go like why is the
moment though no in the moment when you
watch like oh i didn't pick that up last
time you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy
what is it
no i'm talking about this guy i'm trying
to defend you bro thank you
so can you find out what the real reason
for movies are
uh have you guys seen spirited away yeah
no i haven't seen that yet it's not for
the first time three weeks ago so
miyazaki the the creator for all these
like classic ass anime movies right
every single one exactly
has like a deeper
like
kind of social
like story behind it like a like whether
it's environmentalism or whatever
did you know that that one was about
toxic work culture
the one with the pig spirited away
spirited away oh it's about
uh japan commercializing industrializing
and becoming materialistic
and then um forgetting the the old ways
of like spiritualism and all that stuff
spirit yeah the spirited away isn't that
[ __ ] nuts
along the way yes
it's about commercialism [ __ ] tell
me about it then huh uh yeah i watched
it
so much daddy
yeah you're trying to get the toys and
it's not about the toy it's about the i
just wanted your attention dad because
everyone in the [ __ ] 90s was
overworking and every movie was like why
can't you just come to my baseball game
and [ __ ] you're saying it's about the
toy that's what he's saying that's what
i was trying to say but yeah but but
like hook oh hook was the same yeah
hook's the same [ __ ] come to my baseball
game and all that kind of [ __ ] yeah mrs
doubtfire is about pollution
wait can we say that's true and they're
not trying to do it okay
no you tried no you tried i don't know
[Laughter]
back to the future was about littering
was it really i don't know captain
planet is about um
ancestral sex yeah about
my boy orgies bro game of thrones style
captain planet
oh i think heart kids is [ __ ]
everyone
i'd be so down to watching game of
thrones version of captain planet
glory as [ __ ] we're just getting stabbed
in the eye okay i thought we were still
just only on incest on that oh yes
he's like i'd be so down
for captain planet
yes that's what you're saying dude you
know heart everyone's taking turns to
heart right yeah everybody yeah and
hearts giving it
would be over like season one it'll be
like a little used you know season two
they'd have to really come back with
like a
different box
maybe it's different body parts
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah this guy's good at making
porn prayers
that's like his strength like joe is
popping with that my dna is strong
why don't we skip making a movie and
just make a porn parody
i wanted to guys i'm in well i
you guys don't want to do this that is
one of my favorite series on youtube is
you interviewing porn stars in the
[ __ ] bang book thank you very much
that's how i found him first it's so
[ __ ] funny
bro i saw you i saw your prank video
where you're like hitting on people's
girlfriends that was really funny but
that's disrespectful though well i know
i know i felt bad about it
i like when he was interviewing after i
[ __ ] them
i forgot their numbers and married them
every single one dude every single one
he's getting he didn't feel bad
[Music]
you